what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio at San Diego Comic-Con
2023 I feel like you could probably get
a crisp view of our background right now
and see that it's a Star Trek back there
which is very appropriate for my
conversation with Casper Kelly who is
working on some new Star Trek digital
shorts congratulations on those I can't
wait to hear about those but I also want
to hear a lot about your passion for
animation and your background oh thank
you so much Perry yes I'm so excited to
be here uh yes uh oh I don't need a
passion for animation I'm not sure do
you know what sparked it like what was
the what was the first moment when
you're like this is a this is a
storytelling medium and a craft that I
feel like I can make the most of if I go
down that path
um well uh
I think uh Star Trek the animated series
was actually one of them I'm dating
myself but I I was very young when that
happened and uh was obsessed with that
cartoon and
um uh I I told my mom I was changing my
first name to Captain uh Captain Kelly
because I wanted to be like Captain Kirk
and my mom was like well that's that's a
title I'm like I don't know what you're
talking about that doesn't it's my first
name
I'm surprised I haven't heard of people
actually doing that now that you say it
kind of love that this isn't what the
Star Trek shorts are but I know you are
also heavily involved in adult animation
and I feel like that sector of Animation
doesn't get nearly enough credit for how
like rich and thematically relevant it
could be so do you remember the first
thing you saw in that sector that showed
you the storytelling possibilities in
that Realm
um
you know there wasn't a lot I was
probably
um as far as adult feeling it might have
been either Wizards by Ralph bakshi or
um Fantastic Planet was a real mind
blower it was just very dark and odd and
like a dream you know so I like that a
lot too we need more in that space it
does feel like it's becoming like more
widely embraced than ever but it just
always feels like something like needs
that needs to be in the spotlight even
more so than it is right now I yeah I
think there could be more uh adult
animation for sure yeah is there any is
there anything in that realm you would
recommend to our viewers right now like
whether it's something you worked on but
also something that you've seen recently
that will maybe inspire you in the
future oh in terms of adult animation
well definitely I want you to watch my
shorts that are coming out but I would
say uh well it's not recent
I'm kind of newer to anime but I did
what finally watched Neon Genesis and I
was like oh my God yeah I love that I
just heard it influence nope that nope
uh used a little bit of it was inspired
by that too but anyway I'm here for
anime uh suggestions I need to get into
that realm a little more so than I have
all right leaning into Star Trek now how
exactly does one get involved in this
capacity in a new batch of shorts is it
something you seek out or is they is it
something they come to you this one I
was well I did a this isn't my first
Star Trek thing I did a little piece uh
for a Star Trek short there was a Star
Trek short which was sort of an origin
story about the Tribbles and Alex
kurtzman I think inspired by uh too many
cooks which I did and also the cheddar
Goblin sequence in Mandy he wanted me to
do a commercial for a triple cereal so
that was the first thing I did for him
and he's wonderful the whole Star Trek
family is wonderful and then he very
kindly when this anniversary came about
he very kindly uh thought of me since uh
I do things like that like too many
cooks has the 80s GI Joe sequence in
there and so forth so he thought I was a
good fit and hopefully I am can you tell
us a little bit about your role on this
particular project and maybe if there's
something within that role that is a new
creative challenge for you something
you've never done on any of your past
projects
um well
I'm uh sort I'm writing them along with
these two other writers Claire Friedman
and Aaron walkey I write them and then
I'm directing them uh basically along
with uh uh awesome Incorporated the
animation studio and the challenge is
that the I think the challenge is this
isn't something new I'm making myself it
is a beloved uh
thing with a storied history so it is
negotiating
when but you also want to change you
wanna you wanna push limits so put
what's the right limits to push what's
not right what feels good what makes
this doesn't feel like Star Trek anymore
and just figuring all that out because
it is a show about optimism and hope for
the future but it's also a show that
does not take itself too seriously
so many follow-ups about that idea but
more broadly in terms of finding the
right stories because there's five of
them in total what is it like picking
the right assortment of characters so
you know they all fit together but they
they stand on their own two feet as much
as you need I have a true answer to this
which I've learned about myself is I am
not a great judge of my own work so what
I usually do
is overwrite so we wrote 10
and then I go Alex and everyone which is
which are your favorite are and if you
don't like any of them we'll write more
but they loved them and and they picked
five so I don't want the pressure of
deciding that myself so I just do a lot
and then let someone else decide and
hopefully the audience which ones are
which ones they like I mean this doesn't
feel fair to ask when these haven't even
come out but is there a possibility that
that other batch can be saved for future
releases absolutely and there are some
good ones yeah I like yeah uh I think so
and but but I will say this uh and maybe
you're segwaying to this anyway but I'm
doing a comic book and they originally
said well why don't we use those five
scripts in the comic book and I go hold
on I've never written a comic book I
want to write a comic book I want to
take advantage of that Medium I don't
want to just adapt these animation
scripts to a comic book I'm going to
write something new for you so they
didn't go into there either but
something will happen Okay you always
hold tight to that stuff you never know
in the future so with these five shorts
and the characters you get to work with
which one were you most excited to get
to like write for and play with and then
ultimately thus far which one has been
more creatively fulfilling to work with
than you ever could have imagined oh
well uh We've released three names uh uh
Doug Jones Armin shimmerman and uh
Jonathan Frakes and I loved all of them
and uh it was very and uh but I did grow
up with Next Generation so I was pretty
darn Star Struck with that
um but with uh with saru and cork it was
interesting that uh because they wear
Prosthetics that even though they were
just coming in for a voice record uh
um cork had to bring prosthetic teeth
and sorrow brought uh a prosthetic nose
to help get because so sorrow can have
that nasally sound and how cork uh you
need that those teeth to sound like
Quark so that was very interesting I'm
surprised I've never thought about that
but that makes all the sense in the
world well and originally they were
gonna just put them in full makeup and I
mean a long time ago and and I think it
was uh cork it was like There's got a or
sorrow there's got to be a better way
can you just make me just the nose and
they're like okay I have many more
layers I want to hit here just in in
general in terms of the stories that
you're telling here like I love the fact
that that Star Trek is is always hopeful
but it also even though it's futuristic
it has like a Timeless quality to it so
what is it like recapturing those
feelings that we know and love from Star
Trek stories but while also maybe you
know leaning into what modern audiences
want now as well
um yes it's something to negotiate
because when I was talking to Alex
kurtzman I was like my style is a little
more uh irreverent and and sort of can
be a little raunchy or a little this or
a little that or deconstructed or
destroy it and and he he was like don't
hold back just go for it so I tried some
things I don't I don't want you to spoil
anything but is there anything you tried
and thought to yourself there's no way
they're gonna let me do this but we're
gonna see it in one of the finished cuts
uh
uh oh yeah oh yeah and also I was
nervous that the talent would would say
wait a minute you can't have my
character doing this but uh I think I'm
gonna do some stuff and I hope you like
it I'm eager to see it I want to apply a
similar question to the style of
Animation here because it's obviously
supposed to capture the original
animation style but there are so many
new uh techniques and tools that you
have at your disposal so what was it
like recreating what we know and love
but also being able to implement those
new tools to make it better than ever
um
yes well I'm doing it with awesome
incorp I can't remember if I mentioned
that right yeah I did okay so
um we've done stuff like this before so
there's a few tricks I learned
um and uh uh I'm totally blanking uh one
of them is called gate weave did we talk
about this no no all right so I would
I'd watch a a cartoon and it would be a
little bit blurred and a little off
register but it still didn't quite feel
old and we learned that uh old cartoons
were on film The sprockets didn't quite
line up with in the film projector so
they would just move around they'd
bounce around just a tiny bit because
it's not perfect so you have to fake
that and you watch the Animated Series
it's like that too so you you'd have to
that's one thing you have to do there's
a bunch there's a million little things
like that I love details like that it's
not just adding like film scratches on a
like to make it look like an old movie
you want to do a lot more than that and
yeah just to tease the the comic now a
little bit is there is there anything
about what it takes to write and develop
a comic that kind of like even with all
your storytelling experience that like
blew your mind something that is
specific to that storytelling format
um
in the sense of
uh you can only have so much you know
well you can only have so much dialogue
in a panel because you want to see the
art and so you have to pace it in that
way of how much you can do in a page uh
because in a in a TV show you can have
someone do a monologue for three minutes
it's no big deal but it's a different
animal but it's wonderful and there's so
many things you can do in a comic book
that no other medium can touch so it's
just a great art form for Freedom so
yeah all right I'm ending right now with
two selfish questions because my
favorite genre is Horror oh wow okay and
I love Mandy oh yes I think it would be
a real shame if the world didn't get
more cheddar Goblin
uh from your lips to God's ears I would
love that I I will assume then there's
been no like actual conversations about
Mandy too or maybe even like personal
things that you would like to do with
that concept and that character in the
future well I don't own that character
but there have definitely been
conversations uh their things been
bouncing around with uh because I'm
friends with Panos the director we've
talked yeah there's been conversations
yeah he's great anything he makes signed
me up for and I know he's kind of says
he said his Mandy sequel idea and that
it's not possible that he's not so
interested but I'm a greedy Mandy fan
and I want more yes and I still have my
uh my cheddar Goblin box that I was sent
in the mail when that movie was coming
out and I look at it all the time like
we need more of that in the world I
can't believe I was a part of that it's
amazing to me yes it is it is so unique
and incredibly special the other uh Star
Trek right here exactly the other horror
question I wanted to ask you though was
is there anything on the horizon in
terms of feature directing for you post
you log oh yes uh yeah yes but we're not
there's a pause now because of various
labor issues but yes
knock on wood absolutely we like to
speak those things into existence on
colliders so I bring that up just to
have a little positive touch on it in
the meantime we will get all your
wonderful Star Trek work that we will
enjoy and love Casper congratulations on
everything you've accomplished and in
particular these Star Trek digital
shorts in your comic thank you so much
Perry